presa tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono fa vj qui al mio amico di
vecchia data registra ragazze ronnie ma
si sa la notte tra gli avete riempito di
consigli per riuscire ad andare avanti
perché io la notte tre non riesco a
superare la porca ladra riuscì a fare
una cosa decente
mi sono letto un attimino un paio di
strategie per capire come cazzo farla
perché non è possibile che ogni volta
faccio figure di merda vabbè tanto ormai
sono abituato cioè prima mette solo un
nemico vero che sarebbe sprizzava
springs
si chiamava [ __ ] senti lampeggia tua
madre grazie che meglio ho capito che in
realtà il sistema di ventilazione se si
blocca tipo adesso bisogna riavviarlo in
fretta perché per la mente esce questo
si chiama spring trap che bel nome
camero così anche mio figlio dunque
questo tizio qui ti uccide praticamente
solo lui
gli altri sono finti tutti gli
architetti spaventano in realtà sono
finti va a buongiorno e il pizzaiolo
stai portando le pizze cosa cazzo è
appena passato davanti alla finestra
garavini si stava cercando il bagno non
lo so però è passato uno davanti ok
poche domande continuiamo la cosa da
fare ragazzi che se vediamo un tizio
brutto bisogna tirarlo lontano con
l'audio per cortesia hanno fatta allora
ascoltati il cesso e di là di levy dai
[ __ ] gesù gesù
ho visto gesù
[Musica]
no non erano fermi e vola dov'è il mouse
supersoul mano e giro capitana porca put
via via via via via via via dovevi avere
tutto e là c'è veloce al parlamento
ragazzi se prendo un infarto del genere
e tipo questo devo riavviare subito il
sistema perché sono arriva quello che mi
uccide questo è che sarebbe sto tizio
brutto non hanno la no devi tornare qui
si si muove ecco perfetto quando secondo
mi becco un infarto rijen e poi si muove
mi viene ad uscire questo è file knight
freddy's ragazzi un bel gioco quando mi
prendo uno spavento salta la
ventilazione se salta la ventilazione mi
viene a uccidere quel pezzente quel
quello brutto patronali sono girato tra
la ventilazione 20 cazzo dai dai
minchia allora ok mi sto strozzando
calmi calmi che si allora se la posso
fottutamente fare me lo sento affanculo
stavolta serio ma veramente se devo devo
riuscirci sto gioco di merda adesso so
come si gioca
mentre già il 20 lezioni euro li
mortacci tua delle teorie c'è scritto
che non ascolta zio bello ti devi levare
dai [ __ ] capito
quindi tu te ne vai qui perfetto
dovrebbe essere sparito perfetto
funziona non funziona un cazzo non crea
sise
che escono umore bruttissimo ma ciao
ascolta zio e ci leviamo voi non sapete
come mi sono appena salvato non lo
potete saperne e vabbè anche gesù anche
gesù
eccoci ad essi anche una guerra mi
picchiava anche justin bieber non lo so
se avete voglia
grazie justin avevo bisogno mi è venuto
un crampo al piede cioè non ho neanche
idea di come sia possibile che so anche
cosa devo fare ma non ci riesco lo
stesso nonno appoggia quel microfono in
fila
porca [ __ ] ladra che è successo si
sia chiuso tutto troppa roba
ok se n'è andato se n'è andato vero che
se n'è andato vero che te ne sei andato
non è andato via porca put ansie livello
sei veramente bello però ti levi dai ca
ti prego se sì vi aveva qualcosa non se
n'è andato via di qui via di qui però
c'è quasi mai vedere cosa c'è di lava
vedere questo cd non mi cagare di
striscio seconda sono andato sul serio
se c'è dai che siamo alle 2 di notte
possiamo arrivare alle sei mai nella
vita non ci riuscirò mai nella vita
probabile dalla tua mamma ma guarda che
brutta che non si può fare piangere non
so come fare impossibile se io 7 fottuti
tentativi che faccio sette volte che
muoio non è possibile
cosa devo fare lega c'e abbiate pazienza
è assurdo cazzi miei
ho evitato la morte in diretta ragazze
perché allora quando ci sono se cose
strane che compaiono nella videocamera
devo nè da leader
no no no no sta giù saggio un cazzo
quando appaiono ste cose strane nella
videocamera no ha detto che devi stare
giù giù lido dove vai
stan doveva ma dove doveva ogni volta
che va beh non voglio saperlo meglio
così ok quando vedo delle cose strane
che compaiono in giro devo cambiare
subito mi succede
roba brutta ma veramente brutta voi non
lo sapete ma ha evitato tipo 2 o 3 volte
la morte ma iniziare dai cazzo si
vi giuro che adesso faccio un attentato
che dai nomi chiesto ha dato tutto è
stata tutto mi son dimenticato che dovrà
avviare le cose perfetto bene bene così
bene così stiamo andando bene ragazzi
stiamo andando bene forza dai questa
provincia maledizione perfetto ciao zio
come stai dei ragazzi sono già le due di
notte mancano solo 4 ore fa chi è uguale
non funziona manco più l'audio di
portarci di tua mamma bella gran partita
perfetto sono un fenomeno sarà che come
mai sto ancora giocasta roba su troppo
un proprio inno audio error li mortacci
tua zia
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye dai dai
che sono già le due di notte posso
vincere mai così fi.mi delle famiglie
vanni vedenti bellissimo zio quando di
vedere le possibile che ogni volta che
giro a minchia mi appaiono allora senti
no no no non lo sento già muoversi
malizia bravo sei lì bravo bravo bravo
era perfetto l'ho tirato via l'ho tirato
via ciò fatta gioco facendoci che dai
che sono le due di notte
no non ho mai capito mi devi prendere
toglierti dai [ __ ] hai capito la fai
a file zio non si toglie dai [ __ ]
ragazzi potrebbe essere un problema
questo con le tre di notte dai noto via
andato via da donna è andato sia andato
via andato via dai dai dai dai cazzo dai
cazzo hai chiariamo le corti notte
record mondiale nella storia veloci in
questo caso di audio bravi
no no però minchiate va bercy qualcosa
magari qualcos'altro grazie a cervia via
mi chiama windows 1900 ci metta così
tanto a riavviarsi perfetto
dai che scatta alle 5 lei che scatta
alle 5 dai che scarica la tensione ma
anche un banco gli esami di maturità c'è
1 st tensione possibile del ciclo e 55
manca un'ora ragazzi manca una [ __ ]
ora non ci credo ci credo che se salta
l'audio l'audio è stato l'audio malori
avviato subitissimo proprio bike di buy
così rossi c'è rossi c'è mica sei
vincolati in giro
in più sempre con gesù le 6 le sei
scattate ste cazzo di 6 è passato
qualcuno davanti
odio la mia vita dovrebbe sentirlo credo
ok poi ti mando ma ciao bell'uomo
nardecchia chiosa chat e di glen spunta
la terreno scorsa dal terreno spunta dal
terreno vaffan ragazzi è stato bello ci
ho provato delle ore ho fatto dei tagli
ma sto giocando dai da ieri per ragazzi
è che posso dare vita non ho fatto ma
anche una vittoria sono un fenomeno a
questo gioco odio il [ __ ] creatore di
sta roba probabilmente lo ammazzerò nel
sonno dovete dirmi ragazzi che cos'è che
sbaglio perché porca [ __ ] non è
possibile mi sono letto tre ore vista
sono stato tre ore a leggere le
strategie 3 fottute ore non c'è verso di
vincere uguale faccio un commentare su
me stesso e più interessante credo che
questa merda di gioco io come al solito
spero che vi sia piaciuto anche se a me
non è piaciuto gioco e se video è
piaciuto ragazzi cosi tracciato commento
mi piace anche a pacieri facebook e come
nei video trattare tiziana sensi di
simmetrici vediamolo prossimo video
della ragazza